c'est relou si je prends des toiles à
howie non je peux pas bon je suis honoré
de remettre le césar de la meilleure
actrice ah si j'arrive à l'ouvrir
valérie lemercier
avaient déjà remporté un césar du second
rôle en 94 pour les visiteurs et les
joies line dieu alter ego de célyne
durand dans ce vrai faux portrait mais
véritable déclaration d'amour à la
chanteuse québécoise
ce sont ces premières nominations aux
césars depuis quinze ans sa deuxième
comme meilleure actrice seize ans après
celle pour palais royal où elle s'est
fait aussi mise en scène et cette année
là c'est nathalie baye qui s'était
imposé elle est la deuxième actrice a
remporté ce prix pour un film qu'elle a
elle même réalisé
après de longs de mort au cours quand la
mer monte on en 2005 et si les premiers
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mère-grand c'est comme ça que j'appelle
ma mère mais le grand jeu c'est que à
cette heure là tu dors je sais aussi que
tu ne regarde quasiment jamais la
télévision
sauf parfois l'après-midi une émission
de vente aux enchères animée par sophie
davant qui s'appelle affaires conclues
dans laquelle j'ai peu de chances de
passer pour revendre cet objet
voilà mère-grand te remercie de t'être
déplacer avec des tout petits pas pour
aller au cinéma voir aline
pour la première fois pour la première
fois de ta vie
tu m'a aimée dans un film et donc c'est
donc ces voix là c'est très important et
surtout de suite tu es là
tu me l'a dit dans un message que je que
je garderai toujours et et vous aussi
certains d'entre vous m'ont laissé des
messages et c'est aussi la première fois
de ma vie et donc ce césar je sais comme
un gros message groupe et que vous
m'envoyez en tout cas c'est comme ça que
je le reçois voilà je voudrais
j'embrasse comme j'aime les six actrices
nommées ce soir qui comme moi ont un peu
mieux joué cette année
pour ma part je n'ai pas eu beaucoup de
mérite parce que j'avais un petit modèle
même un grand modèle à qui je dis encore
ce soir tout mon amour et mon admiration
céline bien sûr
et
évidemment j'ai eu aussi pour la
première fois la chance d'être très très
bien entouré comme jamais je voudrais
tous pouvoir vous citer tellement vous
avez été bon mais je ne vais en citer
qu'un absents aujourd'hui et pourtant
bien vivant un cowboys fringants je veux
parler de son directeur de la
photographie
laurent dayan
voilà c'est un
directeur de la photographie
tellement palace et de filmer dans la
semaine des acteurs québécois qu'il leur
faisait la cuisine le dimanche donc
chers acteurs québécois et deux d'entre
vous sont là ce soir vous imaginez
devant un quasi de veau chez laurent
dayan vous voir jouer
jouer avec vous
a été une grande leçon et je souhaite à
tout le monde ici de d'en bénéficier
et
parce que c'est extraordinaire moxxi ce
film ça aussi c'est une première fois
voyage un petit peu dans le monde
c'est beaucoup grâce à vous à toute la
gagne on pourrait dire toute la gamme
voilà donc je voulais aussi partager ce
césar avec la gaumont comme on disait du
temps des visiteurs et peut-être même du
temps des visiteurs du soir
avec edouard weil mon producteur edward
je sais que tu as déjà wind et l'ananas
du meilleur producteur il ya quinze
jours ou une semaine mais je voulais te
remercier pour ta fidélité
te dire que je t'aime bien parce que
c'est très compliqué pour moi de dire je
t'aime
voilà et je voudrais vous dire que ce
jour aujourd'hui je dis je me souviens
au québec mais moi je m'en souviendrai
toute ma vie et j'espère que j'aurais
autant de chance avec mon prochain film
sur l'histoire de martine aubry merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]